The Hangover mmm man at his best man at
his worst man at his funniest oh my like
that yeah yeah man at his most naked yes
this is very true as well okay with
those scenes it seemed that I bore the
brunt of most of those it's both of
those scenes yeah I had to look at the
Zak's nether regions as well as mr.
Chow's yes this is mr. Chow's witch's
was it just as funny like these from
them how did you treat it yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think so so what's when I get
nervous all over again
so then was it worth it obviously not it
was somewhere that and and and Ken and I
did all about Steve this movie that
comes out with Sandra Bullock on Labor
Day so I knew Ken really well and he
pitched the idea to be naked that was
not in the script and I was actually
fine with like I didn't even think twice
about it cuz I know I know I thought it
was the funniest but when I started to
watch everybody's reaction to me and I
thought oh I should pretend this is more
awkward than it is isn't that crazy Wow
the truth is like it was very normal
we're just scary does that seem like I
don't like it okay is that good enough
yeah yeah okay all these guys together
just I don't know did were you able to
rein yourselves in and actually get the
scenes done within the time allotted or
did it always go awry no it we did
because uh it's a pact it's a very dense
movie you know those scenes aren't every
scene there's no like sort of
transitional scene where you just sort
of talking and sitting around like the
breakfast tables about it and even the
breakfast table there's 80 things going
on so we it was like very intense
we shot long day long hours and a short
amount of days to fit this movie in and
it was like doing a war movie or
something we felt like we really went
through it that said you know there were
times where we would laugh and
particularly there was one time at a
hospital with with the older gentleman
who gets naked and
and we really couldn't keep us together
for that yes that was election night in
the United States was it really oh yeah
Wow and that gentleman was naked the
gentleman yes he was but not facing us
that's right yeah just chasing you it's
very wide wide but they'll see that one
day oh yes did you were you laughing
when you read the script because I have
to tell you it was it's so funny yeah I
did laugh out loud when I read the
script the coolest moment of the script
for some reason that was the reason I
wanted to do the movie besides Todd
Phillips was the scene opening scene of
the phone call with Phil you know what
he just says yeah that's not gonna
happen I don't know I just found that so
funny
I didn't deliver well but it was funny
on paper is your do you see your career
as falling apart no oh no no as
sometimes a blur cuz sometimes when
great things happen is like whoa did
that really happen
Oh interesting yeah do you see it or do
you have everything mapped out in your
head and you remember everything or are
there some parts in your career where
you just kind of go yeah I don't really
know how I got here but I'm here
um the ladder probably well maybe not um
no things aren't a blur okay
no no things aren't a blur at all I
don't map anything out either I just try
to take it a one project at a time
pretty much yeah so are you good with
that being able to just sit back and go
whatever comes comes are you that kind
of it I'm working on it yeah is it hard
to be like that is it yes person
someone's personality but yeah I'm I
definitely want a lot iiiii I want to
get better and you know of a pretty huge
work ethic so if I'm not doing anything
I that can get they can get challenging
yeah but I've been I'm much better now
much better than I used to be I just
sort of enjoying life yeah oh God like
yeah do you can tell I got so serious
after that question
[Laughter]
I can't and happy I am I just go with
the flow you want to massage do you do
you get a little tense when people say
man this is it this is this is really
funny this is this is gonna be huge
no that's exciting I hope it is yeah
because it was it was I felt that way
shooting it if I didn't feel that it was
so funny I would probably get nervous
because I would think wait it's not good
but I really love this movie I think
it's fantastic and if people do react
that way to me that's logical and if
they don't it's also logical because I
don't I wouldn't pretend to know when
people think it's funny but for me I
think it's hilarious these other guys oh
yeah you know forget it the killers I
don't know yeah no they're sick we have
some issues I hope you help them all and
you all helped each other
Zach Galifianakis are just and grant
let's not forget the baby yeah yeah baby
granted there are eight babies four sets
of twins but grant I think that's grant
on the toaster he was the best one
really yeah he was the go to bluer than
yours because that's one thing that just
jumped on your ice blue blue yeah he had
some beautiful girls like he was great I
just think that when you when you you do
a movie like this you get all these guys
together and as I said again it's really
really really funny do you think okay
what do I do for an encore or do you
just move on
just move on yeah yeah yeah I mean they
they're talking about maybe doing a
second one which that would be amazing
because it's rare for it to work the way
it did you know we really all it all gel
perfectly then there was no competition
I mean zero competition on set
you never even felt a touch of it which
just makes the most safe creative
environment that's very true yeah
you guys were all there it's eating them
yeah it's really beautiful yeah it was
great
so has it ever happened to you can you
tell us about a story where you just
woke up and couldn't remember what you
did the night before no fortunately I
remembered everything okay yeah I never
said I was I never suffered but these
guys suffer from yeah unfortunately so
you remember so so that was a bad thing
so you weren't you're not all perfect
now you're just saying that you all have
I been purporting to be perfect no no
I'm definitely not perfect no they're do
you think of yourself when you think of
you know making it in Hollywood and
doing what all that you do you've done
so much are you are you obsessed or
really really kind of thinking about the
next movie and making it and making it
even bigger and bigger I mean what makes
you sort of content to be true just
enjoy right now that's the goal yeah and
I have to work to it working work at it
every day but yeah because if you if I
don't do that I'm done you know it's
especially in this business where
there's no security at all yeah you know
I've got a movie I'm really proud of I'm
able to lucky lucky enough that Warner
Brothers is asking me to promote it and
that's and I just want to try to enjoy
that and that's it that's all that
really there is right now